hello everyone this is sean taylor field
application scientist manager for gen
script in north america
and in this talk we'll be exploring
the key questions around
the testing strategies implemented in a
sars cove ii post post-vaccination era
with mixed populations of vaccinated and
non-vaccinated individuals
so three main questions arise
surrounding the current dynamic in the
sars cove2 pandemic and the first one is
associated with just the vaccines
themselves
they all have widely varying efficacies
so how is protection assured
post-vaccination in the context of both
the circulating wild type and also all
the variance strains
the second question relates to immunity
and how long it persists
post-vaccination this is a big question
that's remains unanswered currently
and then the third question is what is
the most actionable information in
populations of mixed vaccinated and
non-vaccinated individuals
that we can use from testing to help
assure that we control this pandemic
going forward
so all of the available tests for sars
co2 infection fall under two major
categories
serology
and molecular
in the early days of the pandemic before
we had vaccination the primary mode of
testing was molecular testing which was
using pcr
and that's because
pcr is very sensitive in being able to
measure the presence of the virus and if
we look at this graph here where we look
at onset onset of symptoms versus time
you can see that the viral rna is the
first thing that we can measure and
that's using a pcr test or a molecular
test and that's to get early detection
of infection so that people can isolate
and quarantine themselves to prevent
spread of infection and that's what we
were doing initially
but now that we have vaccination
vaccination elicits an immune response
which generates antibodies and those
antibodies can be measured to assess
how effective the vaccine is
and those antibodies come a little later
in time they're usually only measurable
about seven days seven days to two weeks
post-vaccination or post-infection if
you're naturally infected with cyrus
cove too
however these antibodies persist they
they typically persist for several
months and in some cases even years
so that they continue to offer
protection or immunity against disease
for long periods of time and this has
been shown in many different viruses not
yet in sars cove too but definitely
the model is there in multiple viruses
so
within the antibodies that are elicited
for infection are antibodies that are
termed neutralizing antibodies i'm going
to call them nabs
and these neutralizing antibodies
very specifically bind to the virus in
such a way
that they block the virus from binding
to the host cell ace2 receptors so this
is this is the the mechanism of action
of the virus it binds very strongly to
the h2 receptor of cells and that
permits the virus then to inject its
viral rna into the cell to replicate
itself and that's what propagates
infection
so these specific nabs
block the virus from binding there are
lots of antibodies generated but only a
subset of them which are neutralizing
essentially neutralize the virus prevent
it from binding to the h2 receptor and
therefore from replicating in the cells
so these are the antibodies that are
really important in an immune response
dr lin fauwang
invented a test that uses the
proteins that are associated with
the docking of the virus to the cell
and by purifying just the tip of the
spike protein which is the receptor
binding domain here in brown
and the extracellular domain of the ace2
receptor these are the two interacting
subunits of proteins that actually
cause the virus to dock to the cell so
both the virus and the live cells no
longer are required in this test we're
just using the protein components that
interact with each other
so in this test the elisa plates are
coated with the ace2 receptor as we see
here in green
and the rbd is in solution and by mixing
the receptor binding domain
with the patient sample
the antibodies from the patient sample
will bind to the rbd
and those antibodies that are
neutralizing the antibodies in red here
will block the rbd from binding to the
ac2 receptor non-neutralizing antibodies
can still bind but they're not blocking
in the case where the individual doesn't
have neutralizing antibodies only these
blue non-neutralizing antibodies then
the rbd can bind to the ace2 receptor
and this binding event is very very
strong and
then we will elicit a color change in
the solution because these rbd molecules
are are conjugated to horseradish
peroxidase which elicits a color change
when mixed with tmb
so there are a few major advantages of
the c-pass neutralizing antibody test
and the first one is that it's
immunoglobulin agnostic
what this means is that any class of
immunoglobulins iggs igms igas that
elicit neutralizing antibodies as
depicted here in red can bind to the rbd
there is no
secondary antibody that forces the
measure of a particular class of
immunoglobulins and that increases the
sensitivity of this assay versus other
more traditional elisa tests that are
just measuring binding antibodies
the second advantage is that the rbd is
in solution it's not coated on the
surface of the plate by having the rbd
in solution it's in a near native
conformation and therefore the antigenic
sites
that are presented to the antibodies in
the rbd
force the antibodies to bind to the more
native antigenic sites very specifically
so this increases the specificity of the
assay versus
coated plates that have rbd coated on
the surface of the plate which may
perturb the confirmation of the rbd or
spike protein or nucleocapsid protein
and and then elicit antigenic sites that
may be non-native and may and then other
immunoglobulins may bind causing
non-specific binding so this assay is
highly specific
and finally the last advantage which is
the most important advantage is that
it's a dual detection and functional
assay remember this assay is measuring
the binding event of rbd
to ace2 receptor
that's being perturbed by neutralizing
antibodies so we do have some data that
we
generated in a recent article that we
published in
the journal of clinical microbiology and
there are a number of other papers that
have been published that corroborate
these kind of results
what we did was we looked at
68 samples 45 presumed positive with pcr
and 23
negative samples that were pre-pandemic
and we tested them with three different
commercial assays that use coated plates
either rbd coated plates spike s1 coated
plates or nucleocapsid coated plates we
compared them with the rc pass svnt test
for neutralizing antibodies if we look
first on the right side of each of the
graphs at the
presumed negative samples these were the
pre-pandemic samples we see that the rbd
coated plate assay gave three false
positives
also the nucleocapsid coated plate gave
false positives and this is this is not
uncommon for these types of commercial
tests with these types of coated protein
plates
the only assay that didn't give false
positives
was the spike s1 coated plate but we
have seen other commercial assays with
spike s1 coated plates that do give
false positives and all this is
associated
probably with the fact that by coating
the plate with these proteins as i
mentioned in the previous slide the
protein itself may be perturbed and bind
other immunoglobulins therefore that are
unrelated to sars cove too
the c-pass test gave no false positives
as expected
if we go to the
the positive samples we see with the rbd
coated plate that it called the majority
of the samples as positive 43 out of 45
only two false negatives but again it
called several negative samples false
falsely positive so it's difficult to
assess the validity of these results
if we look at the spike s1 coded plate
it only called 34 of the 45 samples
positive 11 were called falsely negative
and and the nucleocapsid plate was a
little worse with 28 called positive 17
called falsely negative c-pass did very
well with 39 positives and six negatives
and when we looked at the false negative
samples there were six we just wanted to
know if these six samples were also
called negative in at least the
nucleocapsid and spike s1 coated plates
and they were
which
leads us to the potential conclusion
that these six samples were in fact true
negative samples and may be called
falsely positive by qpcr which has been
shown
to happen
with qpcr especially with tests that
have very high cq value cutoffs
in another study in the same article we
looked at the comparative data between
the c-pass test the genscript c-pass
test with a number of very commonly used
igg binding assay tests
and what we found was if we look at
day's post-symptom onset we were able to
see that the c-pass test gave fairly
good results in the five to nine day
period there were a few tests that gave
a hundred percent but c-pass gave 86 so
still
very solid data in terms of sensitivity
uh for this assay even early on post
symptom onset
when we reached the 10 to 19 uh day
period though c pass excelled so it gave
92 sensitivity which was the best
sensitivity among all of the tests
and when we reached greater than 19 days
all the tests performed equally well
with 100 sensitivity
if we go and look at all the time points
combined c-pass was again at the top of
the heap with 93 sensitivity
and we also looked at some negative
samples and again some of the tests gave
some false positives c-pass called all
the samples negative as expected so 100
specificity
so very good data for the c-pass results
in terms of assessing
people who have been infected and
recovered from sars cove ii
of course the major question that people
would have
would be how does c-pass
results relate to the gold standard in
live virus tests because the gold
standard really is live virus testing
and if we look at um plaque reducing
neutralization test which is the most
commonly used live virus test c-pass for
66 samples gave excellent corroborative
data so
c-pass called 26 of the 66 samples
positive 40 negative and with prnt at a
higher stringency which is what's
recommended to be used with this type of
test either pr t 75 or 90 39 of the
samples were called negative and 27
positive so only one sample in red here
was called negative for c pass but
positive for prnt so very close
correlation a word of caution we did
compare c-pass with frnt which is
another live virus test foci reducing
neutralization test and what we found
quite surprisingly was that with frnt by
using different analysis stringencies
the data completely changes
so
whereas with a 50
stringency most of the samples were
called positive
at a 90 stringency only about half the
samples were called positive so it's it
just lends a word of caution that with
these live virus tests it's important to
really
assess and corroborate the analysis
stringency with the true
result
of the data because the data can change
a lot if you change the analysis
stringency whereas cpass was quite
consistent
another article that was published for
live virus assays so they looked at 401
human samples also dogs cats and
hamsters and and between all of those
samples the correlation of the c-pass
test the spnt assay with prnt90
was
very good 99
specificity and sensitivity uh
correlated with prnt9 and there are
other articles that have corroborated
these results as well so this is just
one of many
the c-pass test is
amenable to semi-quantitative analysis
we have produced a
ru a research use only protocol that can
be used to assess the tighter levels of
neutralizing antibodies and
that it all relates to just producing a
standard curve with a standard that we
provide where you can generate a
standard curve and then the unknown
samples are related to the standard
curve to get tighter values
by multiplying the tighter values by the
dilution factor used for the sample you
can get a final neutralizing antibody
titer here's some data that we looked at
with 25 samples where if you look at the
final neutralizing titer
across this set of samples
you have people that have very low
titers these were all people that were
infected and then recovered from sars
cove 2
not vaccinated but 148 nanograms per mil
and then in some people it went up to 90
000 so very wide range of neutralizing
antibody titers post infection and
recovery
so this begs the question
it's probably going to be very
individual basis
how long neutralizing antibodies persist
from person to person if we look at some
real world efficacy data for the
vaccines even after two doses the
vaccines range from 95 percent with
pfizer all the way down to 50 percent
with the cineback vaccines there's a
pretty wide range even after two doses
of efficacy of vaccine
with one dose of vaccine
the efficacies are can be even lower so
very important to assure that we remain
vigilant and cautious to isolate
ourselves and wear masks after one dose
of vaccine because the efficacy is not
that high after one dose
if we move to the variance strains we
can see how the variance strains impact
vaccine efficacy where where for the
astral vaccine it's over 70 percent uh
after two doses but it drops down to
only 10 percent in the presence of the
south african strain that's why south
africa is no longer using this vaccine
uh for um their programs
if we look at the johnson johnson
vaccine um again it's 72 percent after
one dose and it drops down to 50 to 57
percent in the presence of the south
african variant so just
these are the
big questions that we're faced with how
do we deal with the variance and
vaccination and which vaccines are the
ones that are going to give us the most
protection and how do we measure all
this how do we keep track of whether or
not we're protected uh in this in this
wild west of varying vaccine efficacies
so
over the past year and a half
there's been a rapidly increasing body
of evidence that supports the
correlation between the presence of sars
co2 neutralizing antibodies and it an
inhibition of viral propagation this has
also already been shown for other
viruses so this is not a big surprise
the big concern is associated with
vaccines and the efficacy of vaccines
where we've already shown from the
previous slide that there's a marked
decrease in efficacy particularly with
the south african variant and in
particular with the astrazeneca vaccine
however there these prevailing data from
a variety of articles shows that
for many of the vaccines the
neutralizing antibodies the power of
those antibodies is still quite robust
in neutralizing the varying strains from
binding to host cells
so although there might be some vaccines
that are much less effective most
vaccines are more than adequate to
generate the level of neutralizing
antibodies that are required to prevent
the virus from binding to host cells and
propagating
so all of this leads to a general
conclusion therefore that the direct
measurement of neutralizing antibodies
that are elicited post-vaccination
could therefore be a strong indicator of
a productive
and a functional response to sars cove2
and this can be measured now in a simple
c-pass test
so what do we now know about sars cov2
testing
for molecular testing we know that a pcr
test represents just a moment in time
whereby a negative test only means that
a person is negative at the moment that
they took the test
it doesn't assure protection from future
stars co2 infection
we also know that the presence of
binding antibodies so total igg antibody
tests do not necessarily mean that
functional neutralizing antibodies are
circulating
in the context of neutralizing
antibodies we know that they can persist
for months and possibly longer but we
also know that this might vary between
individuals
and given that vaccine efficacy
especially in the context of the
variants can vary widely a c-pass test
neutralizing antibody test can help
assure that the expected productive and
functional response to vaccination was
elicited
also neutralizing antibodies can be
measured with c-pass longitudinally to
periodically assess titers over time to
follow neutralizing antibody levels
post-vaccination
so
what could be presented as a strategy
for a mixed vaccinated and unvaccinated
population
is a combined approach use pcr for those
that don't have immunity
and c-pass can be used for vaccinated
individuals
as an optimal approach to minimize the
risk of a future pandemic